dire qu'il y a un peu plus de six mois
ses rues ses commerces étaient
silencieux sous la chape de plomb d'un
long confinement imposé dans la course
contre la montre pour circonscrire le
nouveau corner virus dans cette
métropole chinoise
premier foyer mondial de la coved et 19
la majorité des victimes de la pandémie
en chine continentale sont dit si il n'y
a pas eu de nouvelles contaminations
depuis des mois à morales selon les
autorités aujourd'hui ça va bien se
réjouit cette jeune restauratrice le
pays a appris à appréhender la mort mais
pour bourhane la leçon a été dur cru dit
elle elle ajoute qu'elle s'était fait un
devoir de rouvrir pour être utile pour
donner du sens à la vie
ça n'a pas été facile elle peine encore
à trouver des employés la restauration
très touché par la pandémie comme toute
l'industrie de services n'a retrouvé que
75 % de son activité et il y a eu une
période de crue après l'emballement des
premiers jours du déconfinement
en mai une nouvelle éclosion
un mois après la réouverture de one
entraîné une vaste opération de
dépistage auprès dé 11 millions de
résidents la phase de déconfinement qui
est la phase la plus cruciale la plus
importante celle où on va mettre les
moyens les moyens d'intelligence
artificielle les moyens de distanciation
social port du masque lavage des mains
et puis les moyens de testing et le
testing sera utilisée essentiellement
par les chinois pour rendre confiance à
la population et que la configuration
puisse reprendre une vie économique
normale
le défi pour roanne c'est de convaincre
qu'elle est de nouveau une ville
sécuritaire une ville ouverte
c'est ce que martèlent les autorités
afin de restaurer la confiance
pleinement notamment chez les
investisseurs
car l'investissement étranger a chuté
des deux tiers mais les gens d'affaires
qui n'ont pas besoin de venir haouran
évite de le faire par crainte d'une
deuxième vague
c'est le constat que nous dresse ce
spécialiste des fois en attendant pékin
vient à la rescousse de maurane à coup
de dizaines de milliards de dollars pour
relancer l'économie de l'argent injecté
notamment dans des projets
d'infrastructure dans cette usine
automobile l'une des industries phare de
hauranne cet ouvrier assure que la
production s'est relevé de la pandémie
au point d'atteindre des sommets
les gens achètent nos produits grâce aux
subventions du gouvernement local dit il
transmet l'économiste boutiana trouve
que nos pêcheurs
sanitaire de lakovic 19 sa gestion par
les autorités et qu'il faudra en tirer
des leçons
la restauratrice gao yatchi retient elle
que si houran se rétablit c'est parce
que tout le monde a respecté les
contraintes pour rester en sécurité il
faut les accepter dit elle pour savourer
ensuite la liberté ici un libéro
radio-canada oural